all right good morning john good morning
everybody so the coronavirus has forced
popular tourist destinations
to require extra health insurance
coverage for travelers yes
so before booking your next
international trip okay
there are some very important questions
you need to ask your health care
insurance
as well as your travel agent okay here
to sort things out
is ben tobin he's from brown and brown
insurance of nevada
good morning ben thank you so much for
being here how are you
i'm doing well monica and you i am doing
very good and you know what i think
after our conversation
a lot of people might be canceling their
trips or digging a little deeper
in their pockets so i was i was reading
several articles
on online and i thought okay this is a
great topic
countries are starting to force people
to get extra coverage
first of all why do they have to beef up
their extra coverage before entering
these countries
and how is that extra coverage going to
be used in certain countries
sure so a lot of the countries are
requiring tourists to beef up their
health care coverage mainly due to the
pandemic
that we're currently in almost every
country that is allowing visitors or
tourists must apply for either a travel
health visa
or require a pcr test upon arrival to
visit
uh the extra coverage is mainly used to
ensure
that while we are visiting or tourists
are visiting those countries
we're not burdening those countries
medical facilities with
medical costs due to tourism okay so i'm
gonna throw a scenario at you okay so
through my research i found that
several popular destinations are part of
this growing trend in our travel culture
they include aruba the bahamas the
british virgin islands dubai and sri
lanka just to name a few and i'm sure
like you said
a bunch of them are going to be ramping
up to this so if i want to book a trip
to say aruba
and me and my family me my husband and
my son were already covered by let's say
blue cross and blue shield
how should my pre-travel console go and
with whom
should i have the conversation a travel
agent my health care provider or both
no that's a great question monica my
recommendation is that you consult with
your travel agent
and your health care provider depending
on the country if you end up with a
medical emergency the major medical
carers will expect you
to pay that bill get a copy of that bill
and submit that bill to them
um they know it's in another language
and that's okay but
if you tend to travel if you if your
health care coverage plan does cover you
internationally
you may want to consider buying a
special medical travel policy
much of the additional coverage
available is supplemental
so it covers whatever expenses your
health plan doesn't cover such as
deductibles
they can also purchase primary coverage
which will allow
to take care of your cost up to a
certain amount so just realize that your
major medical coverage
will cover you if you roll into the
emergency room only but if you get
admitted
um you're going to want to have that
supplemental coverage because that will
pay for
uh for those additional nights that you
might end up in those
in that hospital system just realize
though
most of these travelers are going to
third world countries and their medical
care facilities are not the greatest
yeah so these additional uh
medical coverages also will extend to
um help you travel back to the united
states for medical care if you need
good okay so what if you're traveling
with an elderly person
a special needs child or you plan to do
some rescue ventures now i know i'm
getting into the weeds here but i know
people in all of those categories ben
and they like to travel sure sure
so if you're traveling with an elderly
person or a child with special needs
i would recommend you buy the
supplemental health insurance coverage
the insurance prices can vary widely
while with most taxes costing between
six to 12 percent of the total trip cost
just
realize that age is one of the biggest
factors
yeah affecting the price the rate will
dramatically go up and down every decade
over 50
while coverage is generally inexpensive
or even free for children under 18.
now caveats some travel medical
insurance policies won't cover expenses
that result from activities such as
mountain climbing skydiving or
parasailing if you plan to engage in
activities
yes if you plan to engage in those
activities
work with the travel agent to compare
adventure travel insurance plans versus
versus just the regular uh medical
health
yeah stay your butt on the ground okay
how do
how does the conversation shift now this
is near and dear to me because i'm a
military wife
my husband did 21 years active duty in
the air force
military families like to travel we're
covered by tricare and have been for
many many years
how does that affect us if we want to
travel internationally how do we do that
yeah great um so tricare you are covered
while traveling on business vacation
or moving on tricare uh the rules for
getting care can depend on your plan and
the travel destination
however the best context in case of
emergency and this is if you're going to
the emergency room
uh is calling international sos medical
assistance
which is set up directly for tricare
members oh
wow are you kidding me i never knew that
ben
i'm so glad i'm talking to you today
over 21 years are you kidding me all
right
and real quick uh ben i'm almost out of
time here what about those
like you know uh you have civic groups
elderly people like to travel and they
are only covered by medicare what about
them when it comes to international
travel
and health care coverage yeah so
medicare usually doesn't cover health
care while you're traveling
outside the u.s puerto rico the u.s
virgin islands
guam america samoa and the northern
mariana islands
i know it's there's like very select um
so uh consider part of the uh that are
all considered part of the us
uh there are some exceptions including
some cases where
medical medicare part b may pay for
services that you get onboard a ship
while in territorial waters and joining
the land that you want so
just realize that if the u.s recognizes
any place
that you are going to uh yes
medicare will cover those particular
areas but again
always check the medicare website and
always consult
with your travel agency all right great
information thank you so much ben our
our world has changed thanks to the
pandemic and thank you
we appreciate chatting with you today
all right folks there you have it make
sure to just uh be a little more
specific when you're traveling
internationally
don't forget to catch the moj show
facebook live tonight at 7
pm all right sherry my goodness good
information can i just say i'm glad i
already parasailed